it's a terrific tuesday and i'm gonna go
to get to see baby boatswain and spend
time with him
and see my baby for like the first time
90 day fiance star lauren bravarnick
gets emotional revealing that she's on
her way to see her newborn son in the
nicu i'm really excited and i hope you
all have a terrific tuesday the 32 year
old reality star broke down in tears on
her instagram story tuesday morning
sharing a health update on her baby boy
who has yet to be named
because of kovid the nicu only loves one
parent per day so yesterday when we went
i was unable to go up it was alex's day
and today is my day and it's a terrific
tuesday and i'm gonna go to get to see
baby boatswain and spend time with him
and see my baby for like the first time
and i'm really excited last week the
reality star and her husband alexei
bravarnick announced the news of their
second child's birth on instagram lauren
shared that she and her son were
recovering after he was born prematurely
sharing these snaps from the hospital
alongside the caption quote truly a
thankful thursday baby botton has
arrived much earlier than expected due
to some circumstances he is in the nicu
but recovering well we can't wait to
bring him home and start this next
chapter as a family of four
alexi posted a few photos of his own and
in a follow-up post lauren thanked fans
for their love and support and shared
more info about their baby boy so
baby boaten arrived
late
monday
august 16th in the evening and
he came in at a whopping
five pounds
nine ounces
19 inches tall
he is actually the same size that shai
was when shy was born lauren and alexi
welcomed their first son shai in april
2020 and announced they were expecting
their second child together in march et
spoke with the two in may where they
talked about how their marriage has
changed since becoming parents
i think it's made us stronger
no it definitely puts you through a
couple loops but but we've gotten
through it i think it's actually taught
us to communicate more for real like we
talk about everything now and i think
our problems our fighting
are gonna happen when they're older
because i'm like a nervous nelly now
it's just like no go head first and i'm
like oh no bugs hand sanitizer you know
so i think that's when our fighting is
really going to happen
but for now i think it's really made us
stronger we see different sides of each
other
[Music]
you